almost two years in New York planning
Auntie Mame indeed I'm delighted to be
back here tonight in Hollywood on one of
the most exciting occasions of all
Academy Award night is after all sort of
a an emotional combination of the last
days of Pompeii report card time it's
school time and Heartbreak Ridge so
without further ado shall we get on with
this emotional Smorgasburg by
introducing a very divine woman as
Swedish import and an expert in all
things artistic Miss Anita Ekberg
and mr. Vincent Price
good evening neither Thank You Ross man
for that lovely introduction
yes rise but may I point out one slight
discrepancy what is that if I made a
mistake please I want to correct it
right it's a very minor thing but I'm
not really from Sweden well I didn't
know which one was the girl didn't know
what you mean correct my notes been
would you better be good enough Anita
and Vincent to take over the musical
scoring with pleasure
Anita would you read the nominees I will
do sir the nominees are Hugo Fred hopper
for an affair to remember Malcolm Arnold
for the Bridge on the River Kwai Paul
Smith for Perry
Johnny Green for Raintree County and
Hugo Fred Harper for boy on a dolphin
and the winner is the Bridge on the
River Kwai
mr. Maurice doclock will accept the
award for mr. Arnold's behalf of Malcolm
Arnold I would like to express his
thanks for Columbia Pictures Sam Spiegel
thank you very much